continuing our coverage at the league
meetings here in arizona guy who came a
long way to arizona all the way from
detroit michigan head coach of the
detroit lions entering year two he's
matt patricia coach welcome back to the
set how are you i'm doing great thanks
so much for having me every time i see
that pencil in your ear i think you're a
former engineer you should have a
mechanical pencil not a standard pen no
this is a big conversation so uh
definitely a mechanical pencil guy you
know good uh heavyweight sort of pencil
was great but uh as i got going through
the uh the process of breaking games and
drawing pads and doing diagrams you know
that that fine point of a good just
number two is uh really works the best
you know they've ticonderog has come out
with some pretty cool products they send
me them all the time they try but just
go to old-fashioned wooden pencils the
best always i mean since when i was
working in new england he's always got
one here it could be friday afternoon
nobody's in the building anymore at six
o'clock and matty p would be still
sitting at his desk and i'd be like
would you go home already um but that's
what he is and that's why he's gotten
where he is i mean it's
he's unbelievable work ethic i
appreciate that thanks there's a lot of
times where uh
100 would be god i can't find my pencil
anywheres and it's right there it's just
almost stuck it's ready to go you had
all those years with the patriots won
super bowls in new england how strange
was it for you to watch the patriots
pursue another one win another one and
you're not there to be part of it um you
know what it really it was great i mean
from a standpoint of a lot of wonderful
feelings and friends and a lot of love
for that organization and what they did
for me and uh to help me and obviously
coach belichick you know and the respect
that i have for him and and what he does
and the craft family so just was really
excited for them really happy for them
to be able to go do that again and you
know we're all chasing that organization
we're all trying to do what they do and
uh you know honestly just couldn't have
been happier for them the the big news
of the week gronk retiring you know what
what is the the things you'll remember
with your time with him in new england
uh you know what i mean obviously uh
rob's unbelievable guy i got a couple
great stories really a lot of it
involves my kids yeah you know after
practice uh in training camp and and uh
running on the field and i remember my
oldest son dominic laying on his back
while he's doing push-ups because he
wanted to get extra work in and get that
you know extra pump so we needed you
know uh a 45 pound kid to sit on his
back get a little extra weight going
there but uh just just a great person
great guy um you know someone that just
loved the game and you know still is
still is all that yeah you know i mean
just again and i haven't been there for
a little bit so uh you know all that's
just been the same since i left but on
the field just that specifically too
because i knew you never had a you know
you never had a coach against him until
this year and of course it's the last
year of his career this year or whatever
else he maybe not in his prime but when
he was in his prime what was it like
watching him do work on the field all
the time well i mean i think you know
anybody that had to play him this year
would probably argue that he still
wasn't in the car right now it's not an
easy task to try to cover a guy like
that um you know there's a lot of great
tight ends in this league and certainly
you know he's an example for all of them
to try to follow but um work ethic you
know attitude uh grit grind it out um
you know just just all of it you know is
unbelievable to um you know and he's a
good person so you know you can walk
down the hall and kind of tease each
other a little bit and just have that
relationship so really great i'm gonna
take you back to late january early
february of 2018 the super bowl your
last one with the team in the days
proceeding because i know from outside
the walls of the organization there was
a sense that this could be it for gronk
that if the patriots win he may walk off
into the sunset did any of that thinking
creep into the team were you hearing
anything from players from other coaches
yeah you know what um i was kind of such
in my own little world right there
trying to get ready for do your job for
our game i really don't pay attention to
anything other than i have my own
problems with that do your job right
that's how do your job work there's no
doubt i mean it's just kind of keep your
head down and make sure you know what
you're supposed to do and grinding away
and obviously uh you know that
particular game didn't turn out the way
we wanted it to so um you know just
always got to keep the task in hand
that's the most important thing you're i
mean you're creating new england nfc
north version i mean i know it's got
your own splash to it but just with the
signings of trey flowers justin coleman
what is it like explain to the people
about setting culture and being
comfortable with people that you've
already been with before and what they
can bring to the team yeah i mean i
think it's definitely something we're um
you know we're building detroit culture
i think that's the biggest thing for us
it's about lion pride and it's about
what we we're trying to do from
a standpoint of what what fits for our
team um but certainly guys that are
familiar with me and familiar with uh
the demands of what we expect and and
kind of what it takes to uh get to that
next level you know we talk about all
the time
not letting good get in the way of great
and and you know you see it with guys
that um you know this is something that
we got from doc rivers years ago when he
was at the celtics and uh it certainly
was a situation where he said you know
guys would be like hey let's do a couple
more free throws or let's take up more
shots whatever and everyone be like no
i'm good i'm good and and you know it
really resonated with me from that
standpoint of uh we just want guys that
want to be great you know and um for me
it's just you know that's kind of what
drives me to just try to make sure i can
do everything i can to help our players
be successful it's what keeps me up at
night it's what gets me up in the
morning
that that drive that work ethic to kind
of just outwork anybody i can in the
league to make sure that i'm doing
everything for the players to allow them
to be successful because that's really
what it's all about even though brian
flores didn't have the title of
defensive coordinator he essentially was
last year and after one year he's now
head coach the of the dolphins what
advice would you have for him or have
you given him about how to make that
transition after all those years with
new england trying to take over a new
team that is very different that has a
different culture than what he's used to
in new england yeah you know flo's uh
unbelievable he's a really close friend
i talk to him you know all the time as
much as possible um and anything i can
do to help him you know you know we're
definitely i'm gonna try to do that
going through that first year there's a
lot coming at you from different
directions um and you know what he's got
such a good head on his shoulders as far
as all that's concerned he knows you
just you know to be authentic and and be
yourself and um you know build what you
believe in and he's going to do that you
know that's what he's going to be all
about and
you know i think all those guys down
there are going to love him did you stop
and think maybe not a good idea for him
to stay in the same division with bill
maybe better to to take your head
coaching job in a different conference
or at least in a different division yeah
so i got the vikings the bears and uh
[Laughter]
all right so i want to talk about the
quarterback a little bit your
quarterback who you know before you got
there carried the squad in a lot of ways
and then this year you know i always
kind of just said maybe the culture
change and the different style of play i
don't know what it was but it wasn't his
best year you know what do you say about
matt stafford going forward well i mean
i think again i've said this multiple
times you know he's our quarterback he's
a guy i believe in he's a guy that's uh
works extremely hard you know i met with
him a lot during the season and we had
some great meetings uh whether it was
watching tape or talking about the team
and he's extremely tough so you know i
think he's got all that grit and the
grind to kind of get it um and and do it
the right way and that's what he wants
to do so you know i really enjoy being
around them all the time i think i got
to do a better job of getting a team
around them that can help them win and
that's my job so you know i got to look
there first and just do a better job as
the head coach and
you know keep cultivating the team and
building and you know we started a
little bit of a foundation last year i
think the biggest questions i had in the
spring um really last year year were how
we're going to run the ball and how
we're going to pressure the quarterback
and you know i think that's two areas
you could walk out of the season saying
all right well we definitely kind of
reestablished that vibe of being able to
run the ball and we were able to
generate a lot of pass rush even without
ziggy you know in the lineup and um so
that's a it's a building block it's a
foundation and now um you know we just
got to keep putting pieces around
everybody to be successful it's not
about one guy it's about the team it's
about all three phases working together
and
you know just trying to do everything we
can to prepare those guys to go in yeah
what is your realistic timetable for
getting to the point where you want this
team to be because last year the bears
quickly turn it around that may create a
greater sense of urgency but but what is
your plan how long does it take to to
get from where the team was when you
walk through the door to get to where
you want it to be yeah it's a great
question you know i mean obviously we
got to do it right away you know
everyone there's timelines are now you
know we understand that but you know
realistically i think for us we're just
trying to build it the right way so that
we have sustained success once we get it
to where we want it to go and certainly
for the fans we're trying to do that as
quick as possible we understand there is
a little bit of a a process to that and
you know to be honest with you um the
way that i look at the game and the way
that i approach it there's only one team
happy at the end of the year so you know
whether you're ten and six six and ten
nine and seven seven to nine it's all
the same from that standpoint it's uh
you know i think the rams had a better
record in the end than the patriots did
but you know the patriots are the super
bowl champion so you know for us it's
all about that last game trying to win
that and how do you build towards that
certainly we got a long way to go um but
you know that's what we're trying to do
and just make sure that we have the most
complete roster we can have you bob
quinn i mean i got a lot of respect for
bob what he does is the gm of the
football team of course you have history
there in new england how much dialogue
is there or do you just go i i trust bob
and that he's got the vision of what i
want i mean how does that go down yeah
no there's a lot of dialogue which is
great and there has been since i walked
in the door and that's you know what we
envisioned from the start and just both
of us uh working together to try to put
it together the right way and and as a
team understanding that you know we need
each other for this and um i can help
him he helps me a lot so the greatest
thing is that we we speak the same
language we see the game the same way
and you know it's really been
interesting kind of
being in this spot a year later uh
whereas it was such a scramble last year
from a standpoint of staff and building
and players and trying to just catch up
and especially getting a late start you
know i think the biggest thing people
don't understand is the staff is not
always as easy as you think it is you
know there's a lot of people that are
under contract or um you may have missed
a hiring cycle or something like that so
you're trying to put that together along
with evaluate the players before free
agency starts and obviously work towards
the draft i think you know bob and his
staff did a great job with the draft
last year we feel we got some guys um
through the draft that will really help
us in the future you know maybe not a
couple guys immediately and a couple
guys you know in a couple years but from
that standpoint it was a good start so
hopefully we can get that done again got
some pieces in free agency this year so
it's just been a little bit of a
different kind of uh i don't want to say
a deep breath but you know last year was
again you're drinking yeah you're
drinking from the fire hose you're
trying to figure it out so this has got
a little bit more of an approach this
year which is better well it's been fun
from our perspective to watch it unfold
we wish you all the best as you move
forward and we look forward to talking
to you again soon down the road yeah i
appreciate you guys so much thanks for
having me on i really do and uh
appreciate all the support you know i'm
rooting for you guys all the time great
to see you always my guy right here
thanks so much
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports